Hey look guys my name is Jenna welcome
back to my game engine series so last
time we took a look at Qian Mouse cards
and just setting up all that stuff so
that we can have actual key cards and
mouse codes to find inside hazel I'm not
relying on other libraries such as GL of
W definitely check out that video if you
haven't already and also last time I
asked you guys the question of where we
should proceed next and their worst
responses and the top comment was
basically this
so the I'm Gary talking sounds really
nice and after that I feel like a good
path might be rendering and then like
rendering potential rendering related
tasks like that easy a sterilization
helpful man I mostly agree with this and
in fact I'll definitely do the rendering
like a definitely bad step I think we'll
be good to do next as far as like ACS
and civilization I might actually do
them in the in like the reverse kind of
order so throw that in first then ACS
level 4 mantle scripting yeah pretty
much good so we're gonna pretty much
followed this road map starting with
rendering so and then the I'm GUI kind
of docking and and when doing like the
I'm going viewports branches all that
I've been looking at which I think I
mentioned last time is something that I
really want to do as well so that's
probably what's gonna happen but instead
of doing I'm good
I'm going docking today which we could
do we're just gonna kind of get start up
with rendering I think and specifically
the mathematics kind of part of that so
rendering is very much reliant on maths
like you have to have a math library to
do pretty much anything right I mean if
you want to draw something on the screen
you know we're dealing with a
potentially 2d or a 3d render us so we
need to have you know two component or
three component vectors right four
component vectors usually as well right
and matrices for transforms and all of
that kind of stuff so you need a math
library there obviously you don't need
to have that you could just have like a
float array or something and then just
send that buffer to the GPU and then
render wherever you want because that's
what it kind of comes down to in the end
but I mean since we are not kind of
talking about weird ways to do things
and we actually want to set up something
good here we need to have a math library
so with maths there are quite a quite a
number of rather good maths libraries I
mean honestly Improv Everywhere
worked on in my life professionally they
always have their own so we could go
ahead and just write our own mouth
fireproofing see here's the problem
writing a math library by yourself
technically speaking just to get the
bare minimum up and running is actually
not that difficult you need to have a
basic set of classes such as you know
your basic vector classes right so the
two components rigging about a full
component vector you need to have a 3 by
3 matrix a 4 by 4 matrix maybe like a
ray class as well with like an origin in
a direction that's pretty useful
Plutonians
what else this is just going off the top
of my head by the way I think that's
probably about it and obviously like a
bunch of utility functions as well and
obviously all the vector classes will
include things like dot and cross
product as well as the component wise
multiplication all of that stuff you can
write yourself pretty easily like in a
day maybe less right if it's your first
time then maybe it'll take you a whole
day but it's really not that difficult
totally easy to do to do by yourself but
if you want to write a good math library
that's where it becomes more difficult
because in order for maths to be fast
and in order to actually write it in a
good way you need to take advantage of
sim D essentially which is a single
instruction multiple data so essentially
what you want to do is use like 128-bit
wide registers on your CPU to actually
do that kind of 4x4 matrix
multiplication or like dot product or
all those kind of math operations
because you can actually do them in a
single CPU instruction instead of having
to load registers with num with
variables and multiply them kind of one
float at a time in order to do kind of
SSA or AVX on me on or whatever platform
you're on in order to actually use those
extensions as I say being on the Intel
on streaming sim D extensions in order
to use all of that you need to either
write assembly code which normally does
like to be honest and everything I've
worked on no one's ever you ever really
done it that way but it is possible to
do it that way the other way to do it is
by using compiler intrinsics now if you
use in compiler intrinsics obviously
like i mean that definition of lauren
means that it's per compiler so clang is
different one
then em SVC does write different kind of
you know variable names different
functions all that stuff like for
example in MSP C's underscore underscore
M 128 that's the kind of variable type
that holds that 128-bit Y register
variable right that's the time so and
that's that's the intrinsic to DM SVC
compiler so because we have this problem
of using all this stuff you have to
individually write SSE code essentially
or SMD code all safe for all major
platforms and compilers and even if you
were doing it for one compiler it's
still difficult and it's still like
something that you need to learn how to
do and this series is not about how that
works I mean I might make some videos
just for C++ in the future to do with
that kind of stuff because I know it's
come up a few times and comments but
because of basically because of sim D
and because that's the proper way to
write a math lab and really I wouldn't
consider a math library that didn't
support that to be honest because why
like that's just gonna be too slow in a
large-scale kind of good high-performing
game engine like hazel like that's
because that's one of the goals for
hazel because of that you know unless
you kind of have the time to do that
which we don't then you should just use
a library which supports that so we're
gonna use something called GLM just
called the opengl math lab let's just go
over to this computer here so this is
what it is called OpenGL mathematics now
it's a C++ math library for graphics
programming I mean look it's called
OpenGL maths and it says it's kind of
based on GLSL because it's supposed
everything the jail cell does you see
the syntax is very much like chilla
cells for example it says math for you
know you have your kind of effect 3
instead of like float 3 which is what
hlsl would would be like so it is kind
of based a lot on OpenGL but you have to
realize that this has nothing to do with
OpenGL like it's not tied to OpenGL at
all right it's just a math library
that's syntactically based on OpenGL and
probably the ordering of like their
memory layout for matrices is probably
the same as well but it's not limited to
gel self features anyway right and it's
got things like quaternions which
don't exist in GLSL and I'm sure that in
fact it's made out of templates so I'm
sure that you could probably change the
memory order of you and wanted to
basically in my experience it's quite a
good math library and if we take a look
at the git repository you'll see that
they actually do have you know sim D
stuff right so I mean I haven't liked
matrix for example you know look like
this is like the SSA kind of stuff that
I was talking about that MSPCA has right
like they've got all this kind of SSA
code in here which again you can see
it's quite complicated it's quite hard
to write right so they've got all of
that stuff which is what we are looking
for and it's just a really easy to use
math library I've used it before I quite
like it it's really my grocery math
library I mean I I need to use this or
potentially the directx math library
which is very good but that's kind of
you know limited to direct texts in some
form I mean you can use it with
everything but anyway whatever get into
that we're gonna be using GLM to begin
with maybe sometime in the future if I
have like a spare month or so in my life
four years from now or whatever I might
be like you know what let's just write
our own math library and I'll do a
little series on that or whatever
that'll be fun I wouldn't mind doing
that if I had the time but I don't and
everything and this does everything we
need to do so on one hand and you can
see I mean it does avx2 and stuff which
is um same days kind of stuff it does
it's great right you should use it so
we're gonna use this so we're gonna go
to the releases we could add this as a
get sub module we probably should to be
honest
so yeah let's add it as a get sub module
so I'll just open this will go to hazel
you can see this episode is pretty much
not prepared because you guys love it
when I do stuff live let's just do a git
status everything's fine so it will just
do get sub module add and in fact I
don't even remember what the commands
are so we can add a name and then a
repository thing or at least it has
path repository repository and then path
so we'll do this we don't by the way we
don't need pre-make or anything like
that for this at all because it's a
header only library so that's quite that
makes it quite nice and then we'll add
it into hazel Vanda and I guess
hazel van de hazel vendor and then just
GLM and how to be it's there pretty much
right at lower case all the time so we
will also make it lower case so I'll say
hey hazel vendor jail him okay so we're
gonna add that okay and now that that's
done if we just we literally can just
like refresh this and you'll see
GLM appears over here in our solution
view we can include everything we kind
of need into here we really just need to
include GLM I mean like you don't need
to do much at all so I'm just gonna
right click in here include I actually
shouldn't do that though because we are
using pre make but the thing is we don't
need to include it at all to be
completely fair because yeah I do want
to add an include path let's just wait
for the illustrator to start responding
again okay it's good now so we could
like if we just look at the Premack file
quickly I mean I do want to add it as an
include directory to like hazel and also
to sandbox so you know we could do what
we have included directory yeah I guess
we kind of are putting all our
dependencies here so I will put it here
so GLM and then I think that's it
because then we can GL m /g LM or
whatever that we need to do and I think
that's probably good so we'll just do
include directory
GLM alright and then we can do the same
thing for the include directories into
sandbox that should just work I don't
see why it wouldn't so it's in Hazel
Vantage ALM that looks good to me and
then if we rerun
ah but we probably don't want to include
our but this isn't including it in the
project if we want to include it in the
project you have to add it as like one
of these files that we just add the
reason like I'm not sure if I really
want to do that because then they'll all
kind of appeal actually in the project
when you search and when you do alt
shift Oh a visual assist for example but
then again like we do have everything
else here obviously like all this stuff
from well it's from JLM now because I
included it by right-clicking but if it
wasn't in there it wouldn't appear there
so I'm not sure if we want all that
because it does clutter everything up
and we probably won't need to look at it
very often but if you wanted to you can
just add it into the files into hazel
and then obviously it would be there so
just as an example because some people
might be interested in this we can just
do you know project name which is hazel
and then vendor and then GLM and then
GLM for example and then that would
include everything that I just did here
okay so let's rerun that and see what
happens
generate projects okay so that's done if
I reload the solution now you'll see
that we have
Vanda GLM all of this stuff is excluded
as you can see but this stuff actually
is also excluded so that's wonderful
maybe I messed up a path here so that's
inside hazel bender GLM GLM so what on
earth did I do
let's take a look so we had project name
vendor GLM GLM well obviously I need to
actually like include the files that I
want because you can't just include a
directory like that now what I wanted to
say okay so they're all HPP files I
think that's really I don't think there
are any other I mean there's inline
files as well so one click those
I know yeah that's probably it
they don't seem to use header files or
CPP files because yeah okay cool
so let's rerun generate projects done
reload and we should hopefully see them
included now um in here and you can see
they are okay great so now obviously
they will show up kind of in here as
part of um our pan fountain solution and
all that and that's really it I mean I
think we set up an include directory so
we can probably test it out by trying to
you know include GLM slash like GLM
right and if you look at the sample here
that kind of did all of this stuff did
we include it in sandbox or not that's
what I want to know because I forgot so
let's look at this yeah we did actually
so with that that should be accessible
through the sandbox out so maybe let's
just try that demo we'll go over here
we'll grab pretty much this entire code
we'll just paste it into sandbox Aptos
EBP just like that we'll hit control f7
to just build that file
and then if it builds successfully then
we know everything has worked and you
can see does write lots of warnings we
will address these warnings soon by the
way I promise but if you scroll down to
the very bottom don't know if you can
see but you can see one succeeded or
failed so that did in fact work okay and
then if we matter if we like we really
wanted to I guess we could go over here
into more example layer for example and
then do what's what even is this code
translation five and like one on a
rotation vector of point five point five
let's just say all right and then that
returns something and then we can
probably try and log it I don't know if
there's a there's probably no logging
functions for this but let's just stick
a breakpoint here yet f5 to compile all
this code
and then if we hit f10 you should see we
have a camera with a bunch of values
over here that are inside our matrix now
it's pretty good to me
all right cool and this is almost a bit
hard to read because it kind of alias is
a lot of these things that X and I are
the same variable and I guess so is s so
we have kind of s T something else I
don't know we have X Y Z W and we have
like our GPA and then we also have our s
TQ okay so you sorry s T P Q it seems so
we have a lot of different kind of
aliases for the same variable just in
case we're dealing with colors or we're
dealing with texture coordinates or
we're dealing with you know and just
positions X Y Zed so Jill Chi LM kind of
gives us that anyway you can see that
works fine I want to delete this example
you can try it out for yourselves if you
want to but otherwise that's really how
simple it is to include a header only
library and we can use it everywhere now
I would like to add things like logging
functions to it so that we can just do
something like H said you know H said
trace and then like give it like a matte
four or something like that right and
actually have it have a trace that
properly so to do that we kind of need
to do basically the same thing that we
did in advant way to decide how we
actually want to present that data
because it is a four by four matrix and
then we have to do basically what we did
with all these events which i think was
just you know having something like this
having a two string function which then
eventually was called I think event
calls that yeah we had this operator
which is what our logging library sped
log or SPD log looks for and then we
just simply actually log that matrix
there so this is the case for an event
obviously we could add something like
this in the GLM name like we could add
someone somewhere anywhere we could add
this function somewhere which takes in
like a GLM type like this one and
actually logs it in its kind of format
and then that way we could have that
printing so that's that's something I
want to do in the future and then also I
really want to
and I'm GUI kind of display component I
guess for these math types so that we
can easily for example see a matrix and
also manipulate a matrix just by looking
at it in an I'm GUI kind of window
because that's gonna be really useful
when we start having to deal with
graphics programming and debugging all
of that because next time we're going to
probably rewrite or not rewrite but I'm
gonna put in that docking I am GUI
docking and also viewports
implementation that I talked about being
able to drag windows outside about our
own hazel window and all that which I've
already got running in the hazel
development branch probably going to do
that next time and then after that we're
gonna start planning our actual renderer
and start implementing the renderer into
hazel so that is kind of the plan I hope
you guys enjoyed this video if you did
you can hit that like button you know
support stairs I got a patient on
corsage the chair a huge thank it was
always to everyone who makes this
possible this series would not be here
without you guys say thank you so much
for your continued support if you want
to jump ahead and see what what kind of
up to because there's already a renderer
implemented there's already like a
render command queue there's already a
I'm GUI docking stuff and all that I'm
doing being able to dragon like it's
called viewports being able to dragon
outside into different windows and all
that stuff that stuff is already in the
hazel development branch so if you want
to take a look at that code right now
you can just by helping support a series
on patreon yeah so next time we're gonna
take a look at this I'm GUI thing it's
gonna be probably not too much work but
it's interesting because but kind of
going back a little bit on our approach
in favor of something that is in my
opinion a bit most looked stronger and
better in the long run and that's just
by kind of reducing divergence I guess
from the actual iron GUI development
which we don't want to spend too much
time changing and adapting to work with
hazel we just want to be able to kind of
you know drag and drop it into hazel and
then just run right because that's kind
of what I'm doing like lets us do if we
set it up in a certain way so I want to
take advantage of that and we'll talk a
lot more about that next
I'm somewhere kind of where make this
video long go by talking about it now
hope you guys enjoy this video I will
see you next time goodbye
[Music]